hey how's it going hey guy that guy's
stopping
it worked hey i saw him in the
[ __ ] mirror what are you what are you
i'm trying to shoot a video here
the strongest family in the world not me
look how weak they are they're just fat
i love these tlc stuff and now we're
moving away from addictions to
obsessions
strong and beautiful an average american
family
is just starting its day dylan jj but
this family is going to have to do some
heavy lifting good
girl there we go oh my god even there
above and beyond average because
we're the strongest family in the world
he is not pushing that get out of here
come on honey
almost there
[Applause]
nick cali dylan and
what if i can do one arm push-up and i
never tried it
this will either be a cool flex or very
embarrassing
i don't want it i don't feel i don't
feel like it i don't feel like it oh wow
how do you have the balance
terrible form i heard my back crack
sure let's go with it
oh bracelet [ __ ] see this
ow never doing that again in their
bodies
up to 240 hours each week
i think this is valley question does it
make sense to work out before you hit
puberty i mean i guess you could learn a
lot of technique and get into a routine
then but uh what's the
point all right
three go jj while some pediatricians
warn against deadlifts
let's go 11 year olds
holy [ __ ] 30 pounds i do like working
out it's like my coffee in the morning
if i don't do it
i don't feel right bro you're 11. what
are you talking about with your coffee
in the morning
it's like my coffee in the morning
what the hell squat down lower your butt
pull back on your heels
pull back on your heels and stand up
pull pull back pull back pull back
pull on your heels [ __ ] you got it
stand up
perfect for him nice dylan's sister
jessica
is a normal 46 pound five-year-old girl
oh my gosh jj whoa she's better than me
with one pound weight yeah
it's kind of cute yeah
ah this is just awesome i have no
problem with this
oh so dylan is 18 now so this is an old
video
is that true people think it's strange
that jessica can lift
double her body weight but she loves
doing it and
she's not hurting anything i want to be
like my money because he's pretty and
strong
oh hey hey
look at that our family it's a lot
better than eating sand
at least we can agree on that right i
get can you stop moving around
you're very distracting i already fed
you you're not gonna feed you twice
it's time to start lifting that guy but
we're not normal physically
and if that makes us bad then i'm sorry
then we're back
the family obsession with muscle began
way back
when nick was just a high school wimp my
sophomore year i was 5'3
and 130 pounds and i went through a huge
growth spurt
in the exact time time i found weights
and powerlifting sure
yeah nice nick good job babe
of course he works out for the cringes
reason come on man
nick is a regular competitor on the
strongman circle
where rivals perform feats of strength
and where nick met professional strong
woman
callie holy [ __ ] it's pc piece of
principle and strong woman
she's a strong woman our eyes locked
obviously the first thing i noticed
about nick were his physical attributes
okay maybe not they're maybe not pc
press
um there's nothing more sexy than a big
strong guy period nothing
introduce this woman to k-pop all right
has she seen k-pop
i need to understand it why is
everything distracted why are you late
god bro those better be pancake protein
waffles what am i saying but the best
don't spend all day in the gym
to replace what they burn off while
working out
dylan and jessica consume nearly twice
the recommended calories for their age
i mean they look fit so why not and 15
000 calories in a day
whoa oh
whoa i mean obviously i but
uh oh that's nuts why have i never
thought of that of course he has to eat
that much
but damn constantly feed
just won't maintain this mass here's 12
eggs and this is what nick will go
through
in one day and that's just for nick
the whole family eats ten dozen eggs
every single week
i gotta eat more help the best family
work out so hard
that not one but three local gyms
revoked their memberships wait what
they got kicked out of the gym god damn
it planet fitness
stop it were they lunking too hard what
happened
why would they get kicked out of the jet
why it's just a family
they're afraid because i do lift so much
i'm gonna ruin their equipment or scare
somebody
a manager comes in and looks me like no
i don't want you here and out the door
you go
you're too strong get the [ __ ] out of
this gym
what what
what is inspiration
that's so weird jim jim [ __ ] just whips
me out
i mean maybe they say that and maybe
they had another reason who knows but
still that's very dumb
if that's the case finding the right
house that could accommodate over 80 000
in workout equipment including bro
you don't need you don't need 80
thousand dollars worth trust me
475 pound log have you seen my setup
it's a crackdown we installed some
chains on the top of the garage so he
can't drop it on his head so
that's good that's good he's right that
is good
it's good uh my man you can still drop
it on your head um
[Laughter]
they also had to reinforce the floor to
handle the crushing impact
of the atlas stone easy way
[Music]
come on up down
pull it in i never seen this
some of the best most demanding
exercises regularly spill out
onto the street this is a dog or god
i'm gonna assume dog
oh it says 600 oh okay it was crazy we
all sat out
and watched them we were like what are
they doing
okay one more here one more well she
gets a little
tired oh very committed
the tire flip is a regular part of the
best family workout regimen
from jessica's 100 pound radial
hell yeah to nick's 1 000
monster truck i could do that that's
easy i don't think we're normal because
you sold my one arm push up it's fine we
like to flip tires and get dirty
we like to push ourselves to the limit
and after my coffee in the morning
after i slapped the teacher's ass
[Music]
for five-year-old jessica even it's
funny because usually it's a complete
opposite with these episodes right
it's someone extremely obese on these
tlc
it's interesting the contrast revolves
around continuously strengthening
every muscle jessica is one of my
strongest friends i've ever had
and the same holds true for dylan almost
there
almost good most kids play with regular
toys my toys are tires
[Laughter]
there you go hey let's
when somebody sees go at school they
don't they just think i'm an average 11
year old but when i flip that tire
they don't think that anymore there you
go
that's the keeper that's a keeper he
says
load it up that's pretty good i don't
think it's normal for every
year old to do that i think they'd
probably rather uh be playing a bunch of
video games in an arcade somewhere
dylan has increased his tire weight by a
full 75 pounds
not bad them gains get it you don't want
to be comfortable it's about pushing
yourself into the uncomfortable zone and
getting comfortable being uncomfortable
each member of the best family drives
their body to the brink
and today nick is setting out to push
himself further
than ever before is that tight enough
that's about as tight as it'll go
that harness is attached to a heavy-duty
tow strap
and at the end of the strap this is
balls oh it's a car
okay one slip and his father could
easily break his spine
i really don't care why are they doing
this
[Music]
jesus that i ain't doing that
[ __ ] gains
yourself hurt that bad you really gotta
hate yourself
bro you got some healing to do my dude
when dylan says my dad could beat up
your dad he's not joking no you
can crush him dude i would say i would
argue my mom can beat up your dad
lol i'm stronger than that little boy
and he calls himself strong
not bullying or anything but i mean i
can lift that tire without sweating
i've even lifted a tire as like probably
a toddler
can we give him a round of applause for
a drop clang there
wow that's incredible holy [ __ ]
dude wow that you're stronger than a boy
oh whoa wow
uh he's so strong to the point that he
started losing his hair
well roids will do that for you cheers
all right that was a bit shorter than i
expected but very interesting kind of
wholesome
let's check out child has world's
largest lure collection
my name is will spike joachim i'm 12
years old and i collect fishing lures
my name is katie okam i'm eight years
old and i collect fishing boards but
mine are pink that's so sweet
i didn't expect that uh-huh sure
guinness record what
i started when i was four and i had five
but now i have over three thousand five
hundred
damn anyone can start with four
oh look at those they're [ __ ] disney
stuff what is that they have 400 lures
and they're all
pink i i gotta say quantity over quality
and
the girl got that figured out trap is
because whenever you shake them they
rattle
i found them very yo yo
no rattle trip is the same because of
all the different colors and shapes and
sizes
true i don't true a certain shape
or size i just collect pink fish
[Laughter]
why is it funny such she just wants pink
baits and that is so sweet
catch the same fish this one can catch a
bass and so can this one
i have about 500 signature lures
this one here has been signed by fish
fishburn
one of those oh wow
debbie warner she is a professional
fishing
lady and it's so pink
oh is it oh wow oh that's sick
katie and spike are night and day
different in their collections
in their attitude really i i couldn't
tell a difference between his collection
what was the difference between the
collections together i didn't get that
their behaviors in in everything they do
spike likes to tell her that he has more
lures than she does
she doesn't particularly care why why is
there something different about her
collection that i haven't understood yet
as long as katie has a pink lure she
doesn't care if she's that's right three
or three thousand
i would say my entire collection value
would be
around twelve thousand dollars spike's
collection started when he was four he
went with my dad
to fishing lure shows and flea markets
he said okay
that's what i want to collect he's now
12 and has well over
five how do you get that many trophies
i'm sorry why i can't are we just going
to gloss past that what
what in the world damn
[ __ ] all i got is this [ __ ] what the
what
what what is that i'm just kidding
he's now 12 and has well over five
thousand
in my fantasy dream i would probably
have about seven thousand
lures okay so what kind of well dream
big and you can get it i believe in you
i believe in you whatever your name was
child spike i bet this kid hasn't even
gone fishing before
i bet who [ __ ] cares it's a child
what is wrong with comments sometimes i
remember all my friends collected stuff
as a child but i'm trying to think if i
collect that thing i
i anything i was never into it i don't
know why
i had a few sick pokemon cards oh
you know what i would collect energy
drinks
it was so weird we would think it's so
cool to drink energy drinks right so we
would save all the cans
me and my friends would just line them
up all across the room like
look how many [ __ ] energy drinks i
drank
my parents thought it was so weird
they're like what are you doing i'm like
come on it looks sick like look at all
these [ __ ] bottles
and then they were like do you really
drink this many i'm like no
of course not we just find them
we have to build onto our house to have
some more room
we've got laid out for 40 foot by 40
foot edition
i've done quite a few additions in my
life but
i've never had to do an addition to
how's a collection
obligatory random stranger in the tlc
show format that says i've never had to
do anything like this
there's never been a child that gets a
tire there's never been
okay of this magnitude all right sure
how well we looked in the guinness book
of world records
to see if there were any other people
with fishing lure collections
we found one gentleman who had a
thousand and we knew right
please tell me the girl gets in the
guinness world records that's all i care
about at this point
for the most pink blurs preparing for
the guinness book of world records
we went through plates counted
each lure made sure there were no
duplicates and inventoried them
i was in charge of counting and after
many days of this we have come up with a
final total
of 35 63.
and we are so hoping that you mean three
thousand
five be the magic number look at him and
do that
oh that's so sweet
oh my god to get started counting yes
questions about the process not really
okay nobody else in the town that i know
of has been in the book of world records
so i think it'll be pretty neat to be in
it
pretty neat huh case number two
my mom's very nervous oh my god she's
just a basket case
yeah i can tell and i'm just hoping
that i did not make a mistake oh don't
worry you didn't count it wrong
all right grandma spike are you ready
for the results
i've counted and verified the lures and
checked the numbers
and you [ __ ] blew it you dumbass
can't learn to count is your grandma c
now
sorry i didn't mean to verify that
they're all different
i can tell you that you had
3563 which is a new guinness world
records title
but but what about the pinks what about
the pink baits
she had the record in most pink base
come on get in one record
she is a professional fishing lady
and it is also pink
come on why does she not get it it's
bull
eh at seven all i was interested in
getting was another popsicle
oh all right that was great hope you
guys enjoy this episode smash like
subscribe
check out g fuel check out no legs gang
merch
terraria collab sick and i'll see you
guys tomorrow